good afternoon class of 2019 my name is
Maria Tyson and is my pleasure to
introduce to you our Provost dr. David
Whalen dr. Wayne Whalen obtained his PhD
in English literature from the
University of Kansas and has utilized
this education through teaching at
various schools such as the University
of Kansas in Belmont Belmont Abbey
College in North Carolina dr. Whalen has
been a professor at Hillsdale College
since 1994 he currently enjoys teaching
great books courses as well as classes
on Renaissance literature the English
novel in the history and literature of
liberal education dr. Whelan has also
published many articles addressing
topics such as Victorian prose
Renaissance poetry educational
philosophy and the writings of John
Henry Newman Newman among other awards
he has received a Salvatori fellowship
from the Heritage Foundation and a
weaver fellowship from the
intercollegiate Studies Institute dr.
Whelan and his wife Janet have 11
children and resided in nearby Quincy
Michigan please join me in welcoming dr.
David Whalen
welcome I have met some of you a few of
you one or two of you I know pretty well
most of you I do not know at all many of
you alas I will not come to know I teach
as much as I can but other duties tend
to intervene or maybe the word is
interfere with teaching and so I don't
get to teach as much as I would like to
but I do teach and I hope to see as many
of you as possible
or rather again adjusting word I hope to
torture as many of you as possible
literature is all well and good until
you take my class then it becomes
torture well the college model the
college has a motto and I am here to
talk about it
but let us let us detour through a kind
of prologue Amin on a preliminary
preliminary kind of meander a digression
to begin with we haven't even grest yet
but we're gonna digress but but when it
comes to the motto if one thing I have
to get straight right away is the
terrible tension in pronunciation do we
pronounce it classically we're to stand
Tommy Nick out it or do we lapse into
that sloppy medieval ver tus ten times
well I love the sloppy medieval mmm so
you will probably hear those of you who
are pristine purist classicists may
wince and cringe
well prepare to cringe now I'll probably
be saying there - over and over again
and if you are a purist
perhaps I can assuage your purity by
saying well around the time of the
founding of the college medieval
pronunciation was the most common
pronunciation so even the professors and
scholars of classics were saying things
like vir tus didn't Tommy Nick out it so
will speak of it in due course but to
something else first you you have all
been very warmly welcomed you have been
encouraged in many ways
you have been cheerily greeted partied
you've been assured that while about of
nerves is understandable you are engaged
in a most ordinary of human certainly
most ordinary of American practices
something thousands and pawn thousands
of people do every year go off to
college so in a word it is usually said
you should fear not well at the risk of
being alarming let me say fear now you
think I'm being witty or or melodramatic
but I am NOT I am in deadly earnest you
really ought to be afraid you ought to
be quite scared because in fact and
again no melodrama I am petrified no I'm
not petrified because I'm you know but
it's not a public speaking thing I'm
petrified as I tell my students on the
first day of class because what's going
to happen here matters so desperately
much it is utterly and dangerously
serious things are hard you've heard a
lot about that right how hard it is and
how tough it is the president of the
college likes to recruit students do you
know how some of you know by direct
experience he likes to recruit students
by telling them don't come too hard
you'll have an easier life elsewhere you
go someplace else you'll have more fun
don't come and of course the more
serious students immediately won't want
to come but that's not what I mean not
just because things are hard but as I
say because they matter what do I mean
by they matter think about it what's
gonna happen here by here I mean at
college we are messing with your minds
okay really messing with them we are
reaching in between your ears and
rearranging
everything don't you think I ought to be
petrified
shouldn't you be it's an act of
hostility I'm speaking very casual and
and and crude terms it's an act of
hostility to say to somebody I'm gonna
you know it's a prelude to a bar fight
to tell someone I'm gonna rearrange your
face right that's hostile you understand
you don't need that translated you
understand oh this is a fight but I'm
here I am Telling You and you apparently
are welcoming it I'm telling you we're
gonna rearrange your minds your hearts
your very souls get involved with this
your understanding of the world is going
to be transformed the very torque and
heft of your casual thinking is going to
alter it will be four years from now
unrecognizable as compared to the casual
flow of random thought you experienced
today
everything depends on what we're doing
here I mean I really mean that
your identity is on the line you are
more than anything else what goes on in
between your ears right cut off a foot
don't that's not
it's not a mandate that's not a command
it's an instance if one were to cut off
one's foot one would remain oneself you
are what's going on in your
consciousness that's who you are and
that's what we're messing with hard you
bet I'm afraid yeah I do it for a living
but I suppose even neurosurgeons are a
little nervous when they first look at
that the thing upon which one will be
operating I mean think about it you're
you you may do this or that as a
profession most of you will actually
change professions a number of times but
your identity is a constant
it's your humanity that's a constant you
take yourself with you everywhere you go
you are going there and we're not even
thinking so much about where you're
going you know this a liberal arts
college isn't primarily interested or
concerned in what you do as a
professional I mean we are of course in
many very serious ways but that's that's
not what you do here you don't come here
in order to learn how to make widgets
you come here to learn something about
your humanity you know the you that you
take into this or that or the next
profession the the mind is very strange
the mind is very much like a muscle I
don't know if you thought of that much
but it's contours speaking
metaphorically it's contours like a
muscle its contours are shaped by its
activity what you do with your mind
affects who you are
affects you your mind actually takes the
shape so to speak of your habitual forms
of thought I mean that's desperately
serious think about that next time you
think about what you want to spend your
life thinking about get it think about
that when you think about what you want
to think about
because what you're really thinking
about is who am i and who will I be
human beings I often tell students you
and I mean you personally and
collectively you are very strange in
fact you're a freak and it's not just
because unlike most two-legged things
you don't have feathers and that's weird
enough right I'm sure you're all just
bull blown over by the fact of your
featherless nasai am NOT but but think
about think about how old you are
think about the combination of
incredible human density you're 18 18
what days weeks months 18 years and
you're still in school and you call
yourself smart dogs are smarter than
that
but gerbils are smarter than that you
know they know what they need to know
really quickly and look at you but
you're very strange you are a freak
you're completely bizarre because on the
one hand you can understand essences you
are a perceiver of the nature of things
and you're so dumb it takes 22 years
before you're even you've even begun to
be ready to be loosed on the world do
you know what I mean have you ever
thought about that
you're really odd you're very strange
Walker Percy an American novelist liked
to say and this is a it will sound like
a paraphrase but it's actually a quote
so the man is the only alien creature as
far as we know in the entire cosmos next
time you hear people speculate I wonder
if there are aliens out there just pipe
up and say oh it doesn't matter if there
are aliens out there there are aliens
right here
you're talking to one but but but we ask
we ask here and this asking is
consequential we ask here the big
questions ones that matter we ask what
is the truth it's kind of a famous
question what is real and how do you
know what kind of a thing is a human
being you are one shouldn't you know
what you are what is goodness what is
pleasure what counts as success what is
what is sacrifice
what is martyrdom should I end by I I
mean you should I care about the past
and you think about it that's kind of a
funny thing to care about you know
should you care about it and if so don't
you think that's strange
why is it that I have spent again the I
is you why is it that I've spent twenty
years preparing for the future and most
of my adult life will be spent with
things concerning the future rather than
the present is that a good thing
in what ways yes in what ways no what is
it about the haunting nature of Futurity
that absorbs so much of our lives man
that's very strange how do the natural
processes of the work those of you you
know who think all that gaseous
abstraction let's get concrete okay fine
let's get concrete how do the natural
processes of the world work why do they
work that way
even better you probably saw this one
coming
is my understanding of the working of
the natural processes of the world just
another instance of the working of the
natural processes the world or is there
something else involved or a combination
of things what about that so I'm asking
you to be a little afraid a lot afraid
not paralyzed not you know traumatized
you may get out of bed in the morning no
no no not me you must get out of bed in
the morning right but I do think you
should be a little concerned with what's
going to happen between your ears
I remember do you mind if I step away
from this I'm going to speak loudly if
if you can't hear signal do something
throw a wallet a piece of paper at me
let me know but I'm usually pretty good
at getting to the back I remember
vividly my first day of class in college
I went to a large State University I
actually was one of those guys who
enjoyed being anonymous I don't think
it's the best thing by a longshot but I
was 18 what did I know
I enjoy just being a nameless face in a
crowd of faces you just you you you know
beaver your way along right just scurry
along and do what you do I like that
very much
but when classes began I was
disappointed because they all felt just
like everything I had done in high
school and I went to an okay a good high
school not great you know not
spectacular not something you hope well
I went to so-and-so
no no just a regular place and college
was more of the same I was I don't know
what I was expecting but I walked around
in a kind of vague fog of disappointment
the classes were fine you know
conventional this conventional that but
the last first class I went to things
changed I remember sitting there I was
sitting in the back I was one of those
you know the back benchers
I was sitting in the back and a couple
of professors that was odd a couple of
professors walked in the room and that
that draw drew my attention right away
and they sat down and they didn't have
notes and they didn't have papers you
know they didn't have the syllabus to
hand out and all kinds of goofy stuff
they sat down and they said this class
is going to be a little different to
which entire interiorly you say duh it's
already different but they said this
class is going to be a little different
because you see in this class
everything serious we're reading old and
great books not because of an
intellectual archaeological exercise but
because they pertain to the conduct of
life now they ask questions that must be
asked by every thoughtful reflective
intelligent person or else they're not
really fully alive in other words this
class is serious because the subject
matter is more grave and
all-encompassing than any other subject
matter and it matters to you immediately
and then they launched into an
introductory lecture about the Greek
texts we were going to be reading and I
walked out of there feeling that the
exercise of going to college had in that
hour-and-a-half been redeemed now there
was something to look forward to all
semester long okay
well for good or ill you've stumbled
into an institution where it's all like
that no no no not every class is taught
by two people or and and and people will
have syllabi for you first day of class
and all that sort of thing but I mean
whether it's overt and deliberate and
explicit as I am being now or kind of
concealed underneath the casual
conventionality of the the laboratory
experiments you're undertaking whatever
everything you're going to do here
everything you're going to study is
hugely consequential
it is in fact an adventure it's not
really an adventure that you would care
to go to do alone you don't want to go
it alone
you've come to a place in fact where
there are those who are prepared to
journey with you to Advent engage in the
adventure with you but also to take a
few hits for you that may not be what
you think of as professor or faculty
member someone who takes hits on your
behalf but it happens all the time
because every class is not a script even
if you have a script no class proceeds
according to the script what am I
talking about well again let me give you
let me give you an anecdote as an
example of what what I'm what I mean by
this adventure or even this business of
taking a hit in speaking of Greeks in
Plato's famous dialogue the phaedra the
Phaedo excuse me
Socrates meets this young man who had
just encountered a wise man known as a
saw fost his name was Lysias and this
Lysias had stunned the young student
with a beautiful oration singing the
praises of attachment to the non-lover
what do I mean by that that is lysias
was arguing that one who loves is one
you should avoid love in other words is
to be avoided itself because it it is a
reduction it is a sort of sub ordination
of someone to someone else and you don't
want to be subordinated to anyone else
you want always to be in control you
want always to be able to manipulate and
maneuver and to press others to your
will rather than be subject to the will
of another right don't you want power
don't you want to be powerful isn't that
what we're supposed to desire so you
know what love you want to avoid love
and Socrates listened to
Sneaky's wow that is impressive and then
he amplified the point he actually made
the point more deeply more eloquently
more articulately than even lysias had
done love is right out as a human value
shall we say and then he finished
you know metaphorically speaking dust
dusts off his hands and starts to walk
off and he was actually stepping into a
stream when he stopped cold and said
wait wait we got that wrong we got that
wrong we have to start over no no no no
come back we're starting over and he got
out of the stream and he started all
over and he said it is true that love is
a kind of madness it is true that it
subordinates you in certain profound
ways but it is a divine madness it's a
kind of madness that brings you into a
proximity with the transcendent and the
divine love is in fact one of the
greatest of human goods if not the
greatest I mean it's a platonic dialogue
it goes on and it's very beautiful and
it's very thoughtful and and and
exhilarating to read but that's what I
mean by taking hits on your behalf the
faculty faculty will do that they will
think with you and wit they will get
things wrong with you and call you back
to the starting point so you can begin
again to wonder and to think and to try
to get it right because it matters it's
consequential what would life have been
like for that young student had he never
bumped into Socrates had he gone through
the rest of his life thinking that love
is the enemy what kind of a paranoid
life would he have led you know always
drawn to try to but know right
like I said consequential
okay that was the prologue Amon on are
you all happy clappy now this motto fear
to stand tahminae Gaudet virtue it is
usually translated rejoices in the
challenge or in a challenge the first
word is bottomless li interesting
virtuous means virtue these are these
are synonyms or considered suitable
translations depending on context virtue
strength vigor bravery I like this one
act this capacity worth excellence
Gaudet that's the verb to be joyful to
rejoice to take pleasure in to be
pleased with or delight in and then a
relatively uncommon word as I understand
it in Latin tinta mean a sentiment and
tamina meaning a trial an essay an
attempt so as I say that's
conventionally translated virtue
rejoices in a challenge but I'm an
English professor so I like to render it
virtue rejoices in an essay
what now you're beginning to get an idea
of why I called it torture there are
there are two material consequential
implications in this motto in this
phrase and the first is that virtue that
kind of strength finds itself not this
think about this virtue that the phrase
suggests that virtue actually becomes
what it is it finds itself and is even
delighted in overcoming difficulties
challenges in the exertion of effort
effort effort as a result of a problem
not just effort for it you know I'm
weightlifting who know not that its
effort expended in address you know
assaulting in attacking a problem that
virtue actually becomes what it finds
itself and even its delighted by itself
in that context I a graphic illustration
of that for me I I studied with a man
there well I I won't give you his name I
won't give you his name but this is a
true true story it really happened that
this professor of English was the kind
of person who who became fully alive in
in crises you know if there was a crisis
of some sort boy he just he was great
other times as well but in a crisis
suddenly he was a new man he even
acquired a reputation as being the kind
of guy you go to when there's a problem
he had spent a considerable amount of
time in very difficult combat
circumstances in the Second World War I
won't give you any more details that
would distract from the story so there
was a graduate student a young woman who
made some very bad what's the euphemism
how do they put that date who made some
bad choices
right she made some mistakes she started
hanging out with the wrong kind of guy a
drunk a violent drunk okay so she throws
him out I guess they were shacking up
she throws him out I said some bad
choice okay she tosses the guy out he
gets drunk periodically comes back and
the next day she's beaten up she's
bruised this is not a happy story right
bad stuff she was a graduate student she
went to this guy this professor she
happened to live about an hour from the
University the day she told him what was
happening to her he drove every evening
an hour to her house and sat with her
till you know past the danger hour past
1:00 a.m. or whatever and then drove
home he sat in the house night after
night for about a week and then the guy
came back crashing in through the back
door bellowing like an enraged bull
drunk out of his mind
violent even in his language this
professor pulled a handgun and met him
in the kitchen
the guy was smart enough to drop to the
floor on command and after he had done
this the professor told the graduate
student lady time up with extension
cords she probably didn't have a lot of
rope hanging around this so she got some
extension cords and she roped him up
hands and feet and he stand and then
Frank boo you shouldn't have said that
Frank he said now call the cops and
while she was calling the cops he went
to the bathroom with his handgun lifted
the lid on the back of the toilet
dropped the handgun into the toilet tank
put the lid back on the cops come
rolling in and this guy is still
bellowing but now he's bowing he
threatened me with a gun he assaulted me
he threatened me with a gun and the cops
look at this professor who simply
up his hand like this the cops nod
knowingly hauled the guy away
that's what beer tossed in time and egg
out it means right
coming alive in a crisis really alive
and not not in a silly sort of gosh I
love it when people try to beat me up
way but consequential serious less
obvious perhaps is the second embedded
implication in the idea of excellence it
means something like the the fullness
excellence in this classical sense is
something like the fullness of being
human excellence takes delight in the
trial but trial is that an exciting one
such as I just recounted any random
difficulty to be overcome no it's a
little more serious even than that
because in fact as you have already if
you stop and if you reflect you have
already begun to Intuit something very
real and that is that all of our lives
are trial a span of doing and living and
thinking against the wall of
incomprehension in your infancy and the
mystery in your own death in virtually
every moment we are tried morally
intellectually spiritually it's all it's
all always a trial so the question is
are you prepared to shoulder the burden
the trial of trying to understand things
things not least of which the thing that
is you the burden of your own humanity
and it's a full moral significance Edna
st. Vincent Millay wonderful little
sonnet begins Euclid alone has looked on
Beauty bear
it's not because he had the best
eyesight can you essentially rise to
Euclid's challenge and face Beauty bear
beauty so great that like the lover in
Plato's dialogue it calls you to a kind
of hunger for the transcendent in this
admittedly wide and encompassing view
fear to stand Tommy Nick gout it really
does extend to the whole of human life
actually rising to delight in the trial
of human life this burden and then when
that delight takes hold you know what
happens to the burden it disappears or
rather it isn't felt as a burden anymore
so keep that in mind
it begins tomorrow morning but before we
part today I have one more point to make
there are essentially two models of
learning and you are all besotted with
one of them and it's the wrong one try
as you might you are all possessed of
the idea that learning is like filling
an empty bucket except it's not water
that you fill the bucket with its data
its information it's the mental
equivalent however of gassing up and
it's just about as exciting you know
just insert that you all think about how
you talked about learning you even talk
about what's what's it called studying
briskly the night before the exam
cramming okay that means filling up
violently
it's your model don't deny it
don't deny it related to that idea that
education or learning is just data fill
er up is the idea that learning is just
a ticket took some kind of job you know
you get higher education so you can just
get a job and get realized 30%
aggregated income over lifetime it was
the funniest thing I've said all day
a bilabial fricative really funny um
it's it's a mistake it's like it's like
okay night I hope I don't step on any
toes but it's like dancing for the sake
of health you know people you know how
that works here's why you should dance
increases the heart rate acquire greater
agility limber up the other kind of
learning is what I've been talking about
already trying to wrap your your mind
around the things that are okay what is
Liberty
but it's justice how does the world work
what is God it's got a useful concept is
that the right question the kind of
formation of mind and character you will
take with you as I said at the opening
your entire life it's the kind of
learning to alluded to in a short poem
by Robert Frost titled to take something
like a star and it goes like this
o star the fairest one in sight we grant
your loftiness the right to some
obscurity of cloud it will not do to say
of night since dark is what brings out
your light some mystery becomes the
proud but to be wholly taciturn in your
reserve is not allowed say something to
us we can learn by heart and when alone
repeat say something and it says I burn
but say with what degree of heat talk
Fahrenheit talk centigrade use language
we can comprehend
tell us what elements you blend it gives
us strangely little aid but does
something in the end and steadfast as
keith's era might an era might is a
hermit and steadfast as Keats era might
not even stooping from its sphere it
asks of us a little here it asks of us a
certain height so when a times the mob
is swayed to carry praise or blame too
far we may take something like a star to
stay our minds on and be stayed
welcome to Hillsdale College see you in
class tomorrow morning